hello
if a tree falls in a forest and there's
no one there to hear it
does it make a sound an age-old
philosophical question you might think
but in fact this question was given a
decisive answer
in the 17th century by the father of
modern science
galileo and that's what i'd like to
start talking to you about today
so a key moment in the scientific
revolution was galileo's declaration
that mathematics
was to be the language of the new
science that the new science was to have
a purely
quantitative vocabulary this is a much
discussed moment
what is perhaps less discussed is the
philosophical work
that galileo had to do to get to that
position
and that's because before galileo
following aristotle
people thought that the physical world
was filled with
qualities there were colors on the
surfaces of objects
smells floating through the air tastes
actually inside food
and the problem is you can't capture
these kinds of qualities
in the purely abstract quantitative
vocabulary of mathematics you can't
capture in an equation what it's the
redness of a red experience or the
spiciness of paprika
so this was a challenge for galileo's
aspiration to exhaustively describe the
physical world
with mathematics so what did he do well
galileo got around this by proposing
a radically new philosophical theory of
reality
so we think of galileo as a great
experimental scientist which of course
he was but he was also
a great philosopher so he proposed this
theory and according to this new
philosophical theory
the qualities aren't really out there in
the physical world
rather they are in the consciousness of
the observer so if there's someone
looking at a tomato
the redness isn't really out there on
the surface of the tomato
rather it's in the consciousness of the
person observing it
or if someone's eating paprika the
spiciness
isn't really inside the paprika it's
rather in the consciousness of the
person
eating the paprika or to return to the
example we started with
if there's a huge tree crashing down in
a forest
but there's no one there to hear it no
observer no consciousness
no sound so galileo as it were
stripped the physical world of its
qualities
and after he'd done that all that
remained were the purely
quantitative features of mata things
that can be captured in mathematical
geometry things like size
shape location motion properties we can
model in mathematics
um so so in galileo's world view there's
this radical division in nature between
two domains
on the one hand the domain of the purely
quantitative domain of science on the
one hand
and the qualitative domain of
consciousness on the other so on the one
hand
the domain of science with its purely
quantitative properties of size
shape location motion and on the other
hand
cut the domain of consciousness
consciousness with its qualities of
colors
sounds smells and tastes so this is the
start of mathematical
physics which has gone incredibly well
but what we've forgotten i think is that
it was never
intended that physics should be a
complete
description of reality the whole project
was premised
on putting consciousness outside of the
domain of science
okay so why does this matter well i
think this has crucial implications
for the area i work in namely the
science and philosophy of consciousness
i want to start by clearing up a little
bit of ambiguity the word consciousness
is is a very ambiguous word often people
use it to mean
something quite sophisticated like
self-consciousness
awareness of one's own existence this is
something quite sophisticated that we
might be reluctant to ascribe to many
non-human animals it's not clear
a rabbit is aware of its own existence
but all that i'm going to mean you know
all that's generally meant in these
discussions
by the word consciousness it's probably
a little bit of a misleading word really
all it really means is experience
pleasure pain visual or auditory
experience these are all forms
of consciousness so consciousness in
this sense is certainly
something where we'd be happy to ascribe
quite generally
in the animal kingdom whether or not a
rabbit is aware of its own existence
it certainly has experiences if you're
cruel enough to put a knife in a rabbit
it's going to feel pain so i don't think
it's difficult to define what we mean by
consciousness
the challenge the problem of
consciousness is how consciousness fits
into our scientific world view
despite great progress in our standard
understand
sorry great progress in our scientific
understanding of the brain
we still don't really have even the
beginnings of an explanation
of how complicated electrochemical
signaling
is somehow able to give rise to an inner
subjective world
of colors and sounds and smells and
tastes
that each of us knows every second of
waking life
so this is the profound challenge
consciousness poses to the sciences
now it's although it's broadly agreed
that there is a profound challenge here
uh one very common reaction is to say
okay there's a problem but we just need
to
plug away with our standards methods of
investigating the brain just do a little
bit more neuroscience maybe cognitive
science and will crack it one thing i'm
keen to press in my work as a
philosopher of consciousness
is upon reflection it turns out this is
isn't just another scientific problem in
many ways this is
the problem of consciousness is
absolutely unique among scientific
problems
and in fact that the standard tools of
scientific investigation
are not really equipped to deal with it
at least not entirely
okay so let's explore that a little bit
more
a little bit of water
okay so so one way of pressing this is
just to make the point that
consciousness is not publicly observable
you can't look inside somebody's head
and see
their feelings and experiences we know
about consciousness not from observation
and experiment
but from our immediate awareness of our
own feelings and experiences
now science is used to dealing with
unobservables fundamental particles like
electrons and quarks for example
can't be directly observed but there's
an important difference
fundamental particles and other
unobservable science postulates
are postulated in order to explain what
we can observe
electrons and quarks are postulated as
part of the standard model of particle
physics
which is a theory that explains an
incredible range of observable phenomena
in the unique case of consciousness in
contrast the thing we are trying to
explain
is unobservable and that is utterly
unique
among scientific problems
and it really constrains our capacity to
deal with it
experimentally okay so
but that doesn't mean that we can't deal
with it experimentally we do have
a well-developed and robust experimental
science of consciousness so how do we do
that if consciousness is not observable
how do we have us
how do we deal with experimentally well
you can't observe someone's feelings
experiences but fortunately
you can ask them right you can ask them
what they're feeling and experiencing
and rely on their testimony about their
private unobservable experiences and if
you do that while you're scanning their
brain with an fmri scanner or
or eeg you can correlate various kinds
of brain activity
with various kinds of conscious
experience
we can discover that certain kinds of um
brain activity always go along with say
a feeling of hunger
or an experience of red and we can get
more systematic about this there are
various proposals about
what in general is the correlation
between brain activity
and consciousness and this is really
crucial data
but it's not itself a complete theory of
consciousness
and that's because what we ultimately
want from a theory of consciousness
is an explanation of those correlations
why is it that a certain kind of brain
activity
comes along with an experience of red
why is it that brain activity
goes along with any kind of conscious
experience this is what we want
explained
and because consciousness is
unobservable
this is not a question we can just
answer just doing more experiments
so the upshot is um
experimental work is important
but it leaves open multiple options i
think it's a little bit like the
situation
in quantum mechanics quantum mechanics
is one of our most successful scientific
theories
in terms of prediction so much of our
modern technology is based on it
problem is no one knows what the hell
that theory is telling us about reality
and there are various interpretations
the many worlds interpretation
copenhagen interpretation um bohmian
interpretation and so on
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you